so let's say that they do raise rates
our expectation would be that risks
assets or kind of technology growth
stocks whatever they all are going to
sell off to some degree they already
have they already have i think they
already have but and maybe they go lower
maybe they don't
how long can they last with those risk
assets selling off or is there a period
where they kind of capitulate from like
the fed level and they're just like okay
like this is enough bleeding to some
degree we either need to stabilize the
rate and go ahead and tell the market
we're not going to raise past a certain
point or they need to provide more
quantitative easing or use one of the
other tools in their toolbox where they
kind of try to find like a almost like a
market equilibrium right we were going
up a time now we're going down like do
they eventually just try to stabilize us
somewhere and say like okay enough is
enough on the downside like here's where
we want to stay well that's an
interesting point because actually in a
normal sort of central bank policy the
fed shouldn't be worried about asset
prices like the fed should be worried
about inflation and then lately they
expanded their mandate and said we
should be worried about um
about employment
numbers yeah but they shouldn't be
worried about setting but
remember they were day trading the
assets yeah the fact is i do think they
are by the way i do think it is smart
from them to be worried because uh but
that's sort of my geopolitical view we i
think we all agree the us is in kind of
a silent war with china yeah and i think
at the end it's not gonna
go into an armed conflict but what will
decide sort of this conflict or this
race is the speed of technological
innovation so if i would be sitting in
an administration yeah i would think day
and night how can i make sure that my
country the u.s is sort of at the
forefront of every technological
innovation and i know a lot of media
people and investors made a little bit
of fun and yes there was like
craziness in the market where things
which maybe are not worth anything or
not worth a lot were hyped but if we
take a step back and look at the last 10
years or especially the last let's say
three years five years actually because
of the let's call it easy money a lot of
great stuff was financed so a lot of
things which are positively happening
now yeah are happening because money is
cheap and money is easy but it's driving
our society and technological innovation
forward so i would actually say i think
they will never admit it but i
personally do believe that sort of a
thriving environment for
growth stocks yeah not to make that's a
cynical few the rich richer but actually
to make the country more competitive
towards especially china yeah is a
strategy the fed is uh is
the administration again i think it's
almost intermingled administration and
fed is doing yeah and it's the right
thing to do i do think though for this
year as i said before the political
agenda prevails so i think the fed will
more focus on sort of appeasing people
and trying to show we're doing something
against inflation then fostering
innovation so i do think growth dogs
won't have an easy year but again i just
want to quote her because i think she
she wrote this awesome piece
cassie woods before like it was right
around christmas uh where she had this
term like actually growth stocks are in
deep value territory and i think so they
already sold off so
again i'm not a trader yeah i build
companies i own all the stocks for a
long time but my gut feeling is like uh
if i look again at some of my portfolio
companies which i can charge the
sell-off was crazy yeah and it's
extremely undervalued yeah when you
think about um
an asset like maybe bitcoin for example
right which to me is like the ultimate
risk asset from the traditional one now
many people in the crypto market would
say hey bitcoin is you know boo burn
coin or it's the least risky of all of
them um and the long tail of crypto
assets are even more risky so take those
people out for a second just at the
traditional market side they look as
bitcoin as kind of the the digital
frontier or the most risky asset uh
should we expect that to be the leading
indicator of risk assets or actually is
it decoupling like how do you look at
the relationship between like a bitcoin
and some of these growth stocks and
other things should they move in tandem
maybe it doesn't matter like what do you
think it's a good question because like
i do think factually they move in tandem
i think they should decouple but they
sort of don't at least not on these days
and weeks when the swings are broad i
think if we would look if we will look
back in like five years i think there
will have been a certain
decoupling but at the moment i think
they still very much correlated yeah
because it's the same people like in a
positive way like who is excited about
bitcoin it's sort of rather the younger
people more and more institutions are
moving in but it's sort of the miami
crowd yeah who is excited about
disruption or whatever again miami crowd
like it's sort of there is i think not
because the assets are somehow or the
the ethicals are related it's more like
that the people who get it
there is a big overlap between the
believers in in crypto and especially in
bitcoin and the believers in
disruptive technology